[Música]
saludo protocolar para los policías
muertos en un lugar de culto el funeral
tuvo lugar a medida que aumenta el
número de víctimas por el atentado en la
mezquita
desde 2006 estamos hartos del terrorismo
y miles de personas han perdido la vida
pedimos ayuda al mundo
tras un breve viaje a shaward para
visitar los heridos en el hospital El
Primer Ministro de Pakistán tuiteó la
magnitud de la tragedia humana es
inimaginable esto es nada menos que un
ataque contra Pakistán la masacre en una
mezquita abarrotada durante las
oraciones de la tarde es solo el último
episodio de los años de lucha de
Pakistán contra el terrorismo no está
claro como el terrorista suicida se coló
en el recinto amurallado de una zona de
alta seguridad un comandante de los
talibanes pakistaníes reivindicó
inicialmente el atentado en un tweet sin
embargo horas más tarde el portavoz del
grupo militante suní declaró que no era
su política atacar mezquitas
en 2007 como una red de grupos
militantes los talibanes de Pakistán o
ttp han protagonizado la insurgencia
para expulsar la influencia islamabat la
capital pakistaní de las zonas tribales
a lo largo de la frontera afgana para
instaurar un califato basado en la
sharia históricamente el grupo ha
mantenido estrechos vínculos con al
qaeda y ha prometido lealtad a los
talibanes en Afganistán
aunque los gobernantes afganos han
afirmado en repetidas ocasiones que no
permitirían que nadie utilice su suelo
para atentar contra otro país han sido
acusados de dar cobijo a militantes de
la insurgencia pakistaní
el año pasado los talibanes afganos
mediaron en un alto el fuego entre el
ttp e islamabat pero los militantes
pakistaníes pusieron fin a esa tregua en
noviembre lo que provocó un repunte de
la violencia